Booth: I was born with the chance
to be somebody.
I’m gonna be the most famous man
in the whole world.
Mr. President.
The Confederacy is dead,
the Union is saved,
the war is over.
(Audience cheering)
(Audience screaming)
Freedom for the South!
- What happened?
- President’s been shot.
Parker: Witnesses are saying
it was John Wilkes Booth.
Wait, the actor?
Do you know who I am?
I’m a symbol.
Stanton: How does a well-known actor
commit murder
in front of an audience
of 1500 people and escape?
Find the man that killed my husband.
Gentleman, I am tasking you
with the capture of John Wilkes Booth.
♪ All of this can be broken ♪
♪ Hold your devil by his spoke
And spin him to the ground ♪
This is a conspiracy
to dismember our government.
I know who you are, Mr. Booth.
You gonna help us or not?
There’s a bounty on the head of Booth,
and I intend to collect.
Booth is being protected
by the Confederacy.
Now with Lincoln out of the way,
this country belongs to us.
I will not surrender!
May God be my judge!
♪ “Devil's Spoke”
by Laura Marling ♪
Booth: God bless America.